quick update about private prisons and
the federal government's use of private
prisons you remember that earlier this
year the Department of Justice made this
big announcement and it made bait major
major headlines a lot of people super
happy about it saying we are going to
phase out our use of private prisons for
federal prisoners now there were so many
ifs ands buts and caveats with this
thing that we spent like 10 minutes just
listing caveats for example most
prisoners are not held in federal
facilities they are held in state
facilities so it has no bearing on that
number two most prisoners are not held
in private prisons at all and that while
private prisons are inherently
ridiculous the idea that we would make
profitable the the idea of
rehabilitation of people who have
committed crimes most prisoners aren't
in private prisons anyway so oftentimes
how big of a problem that is is also
overstated however it's not going to
happen because when the first contracts
that were supposedly going to not be
renewed came up for renegotiation this
fall the Federal Bureau of Prisons the
Bo p very quietly decided to renew them
anyway even though the federal
government said they weren't going to be
in that decision along with the election
of President Donald mean that it is
pretty unlikely that the US is going to
see a reduction in private prison
operators anytime soon core civic also
known as CCA it's one of the largest uh
prison operators private prison
operators announced that hey we renewed
our contract with the Bo p and we're
gonna be running the McRae Correctional
Facility in Georgia for another two
years the only change to the agreement
since the last deal was that there would
be an eight percent reduction in inmate
beds obviously the ACLU is concerned uh
having a system where prisons look for
profits it's like having a fire
department that's looking for a profit
oh wait a second it's like having a
health care system that's looking for a
profit hey we have that and it makes
absolutely no sense not everything needs
to be profitable Pat I mean that yeah
that we can't seem to get Republicans to
understand that this was the glimmer of
hope I guess for phase
private presence in the end that's gone
away of course they're gonna cut things
like educational opportunities because
that would go against those prisoners
coming back to them and making more
money off of them no doubt about it and
when you look at it you know the private
prison federal deals I don't think I
have to restate my view which is it
would be great to eliminate those but
those are not the primary driver for the
problem we have with mass incarceration
I know you're probably sick of hearing
me say this by now but the war on drugs
we can't book begin to really solve the
incarceration issue until we deal with
the war on drugs cannabis legalization
is something that is going to help us do
that but think about all the money that
is tied up with the war on drugs we're
talking about everything from the drug
testing industry the alcohol industry
the private prison industry is part of
that addiction recovery law enforcement
civil forfeiture and asset seizure
seizures the DEA the ATF many people pat
don't get how many billions of dollars
are being made by all sorts of people
based on the war on drugs and its
funding police departments police
departments make a ton of money by
seizing assets in marijuana distribution
raids now they've got cars to sell
they've got cash in all sorts of assets
yeah I'm sure it's a multi-billion
dollar industry and the fact that it's
it to the detriment of people's human
rights is shameful its job it's shameful
is really the way to describe it and you
know I mean yes this is disappointing
that we are seeing some of these
contracts that supposedly were not going
to be renewed getting renewed at the
time I was careful not to overstate the
importance it was more symbolic than
anything else and listen if you're
looking for symbolic victories under
President Donald I anticipate that
they're going to be few and far between
make sure to give us a like on facebook
facebook live streams I've been doing
these three or four times a week I will
connect I will chat with viewers about
upcoming stories on the show take
questions etc make sure you like our
facebook page at facebook.com slash
david pakman show and you will be
notified when we go live on facebook